now that we've got the background image
of our new location let's go ahead and
get some more information about the new
city for that let's start by pulling up
some New York Times articles about it
the New York Times provides an article
search API that pulls articles from 1851
to today this request will be a bit more
complicated than simply creating a URL
string for an image tag to start we'll
need an API key
many api's want you to use a special
name called an API key to identify
yourself when you access their data
there are a lot of reasons for this
for instance they might want to limit
the rate of your request so they don't
get overwhelmed as long as you aren't
issuing thousands of get requests per
day to this app you probably won't need
to worry about a rate limit but all of
your requests still need to have your
key attached to them
the New York Times uses their own API
key so you'll need to sign up for a free
account in order to complete the project
another thing you'll sometimes run into
is authentication services like Facebook
and Twitter use OAuth to authenticate
users they only want people with
accounts to be able to get data since
that data is often not publicly
accessible you won't have to worry about
authentication for this course but if
you want to build more involved
applications with services like Facebook
that's something you'll have to figure
out luckily most services that require
authentication also provide getting
started guides with example code and
detailed explanations for now head over
to the link in the instructor notes for
requesting a New York Times API key and
follow the instructions here after you
got your key check this box right here
to let us know you're ready to keep
going